You should definitely be sampling both sides of the news.
If you're not looking at Fox news and CNN, you don't know what's happening.
So.
Trapped in your bubble, and it's becoming a self fulfilling prophecy.
What's the first step to breaking out of your loser thing.
Well, it's good to know what all the various parts of loser think are.
And I go through them like, don't be a mind reader.
Don't predict the future with analogies history.
Doesn't predict the slippery slope. Isn't a real, yeah, fair.
Enough. I want to go through a few of them.
Without details. So it's good to know what those are, but beyond that,
you should definitely be sampling both sides of the news.
If you're not looking at Fox news and CNN,
you don't know what's happening because I've tried doing that.
Try to pick a topic. And before you've heard what the other says,
just consume one silo, and then you go over to the other one. And you're like,
what? I didn't know anybody was saying, this,
are you telling me these facts are real and it doesn't matter which way you're
going. They're completely different.
But is it almost impossible to break out of that? I mean,
we all talk about this all the time. We're catering news to ourselves.
The algorithms are feeding us things that reinforce our thoughts already,
but is it almost impossible to break out of it? Because in a weird way,
psychologically, we don't want to break out of it. I know some people do,
but that most of us kind of, we just, you know, it's not sound corny.
We that's the safe space we find and we're good and we're reinforced and it's
warm. And.
This is why I sort of sneak in the back door. If I said to you, Dave,
I'm going to get you to change teams, whatever your team is, Democrat,
Republican doesn't matter. You would immediately say, or, you know,
you'd be like, everything you shooting at me is bouncing off my field.
But if I say here's how you should think in the, you know,
in any situation you want to have something to compare something to a very
simple statement. People accept that. Cause that's just, you know,
reasonable on its surface. And then you take that through. All right, now,
apply this to your thinking.
So you can sometimes get people to talk themselves out of their position by
giving them better tools.
But you can't just say change teams because you're on the wrong team.
How much of this do you think is just base human psychology?
Just sort of the stuff we're born with that certain people are just sort of more
programmed to go to just things that reinforce their beliefs.
And some people are just programmed to actually being a little bit more open.
I think all of these things have a, you know,
you're born with a certain set of gifts and intelligence, et cetera,
but in loser, think I talk about how, uh, your,
the experience you've had across domains is what gives you better vision.
So for example, if you'd never, um, been exposed to economics,
I've got a degree in economics. You wouldn't know how economists think.
So you might run into a concept like a sunk cost.
And if you'd never been exposed to this, you might say, well,
I have common sense. And people would say, we've already spent all this money.
So we better keep investing because I don't want to waste that money I already
spent. That's not sensible. And economists say, no,
the money that's gone should not influence your next decision because it's gone.
Now, the first time you hear that, you say, Oh yeah,
like you don't need to read a book on it. You just hear it.
And so I tried to make it as simple as that.
You just got to hear it once and then you say, Oh yeah, that makes sense.
Yeah. So you don't think,
so you think we all have sort of pre-programmed abilities to be flexible on some
of these things, but,
but you think that that can pretty much always be different levels.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
people are more or less locked in more or less team players,
more or less capable of, you know, looking at details and thinking properly,
but everybody can do.
Yeah.
Do you think the Internet's changing that just relative to the speed that we get
information and the fact that you can now go out there and find roughly a
good Jillian voices in two minutes that might be able to help break some of your
stuff. Okay.
Tell you the biggest problem. I think,
and this is a brand new thought is that we are as humans,
we're copiers or imitators. So if you wait until the internet,
what kind of thinking style are you going to see the worst?
And people will imitate it. So they'll say, for example, Hey,
your side did X and what's the most common response your side did that.
What did that help? That help? Nothing. There wasn't even on the topic,
you didn't even talk about, you're talking. If they're going to do it,
we have to do it. Right. So some of it is of course,
power and influence and persuasion and all that. And nobody's trying to think,
so you have to, you have to be able to weed out. Okay.
Was anybody even trying or are they just persuading?
Yeah. Do you think most of us just don't want to try though at some level,
I mean, most people just kind of,
they don't want to think about beings that seriously,
because that brings up a lot of deep existential stuff.
Yeah. Maybe, maybe,
maybe there's there are lots of reasons we don't want to be wrong.
We don't like to be embarrassed. We don't like to change your mind.
We don't want to disappoint the team and we're influenced by what we see.
So we just join in and say, well, that's what my team's doing.
I guess I'll do something.
So you talk about, uh, some of the dumb ideas that are floating around. So,
uh, that thus create our own bubbles.
So I wanted to go through a couple of them, uh,
cause we hear these all the time and they sorta sound right,
but you don't quite think they are. Right. Uh,
we know when history will repeat itself. And when it won't,
we hear this all the time, history repeats, history repeats itself.
And because it has a phrase and we've heard the phrase,
we give it weight because the brain will say, well, it's a saying,
I'm pretty sure I've seen that on a bumper sticker.
So there must be something about that.
But it's an illusion caused by the fact that we don't notice when history
doesn't repeat, which is most of the time.
And why is it the history doesn't repeat because it can't,
there's never two situations that it was named, the variables have changed.
And if nothing else has changed, you saw what, what went wrong the last time.
So you, so you fix it this time.
So it's a complete illusion that we can predict the future because this time is
like that last time the most you can do is say, people are still selfish,
stupid. It, all those things.
So if you put it in a situation where they can steal, well sure. They'll steal.
You know, not everybody,
but if you have enough people introduced to a situation where you can steal
something, somebody is going to take a run at it,
but that's not really history repeating.
You would say a better way to say it would be something like themes repeat
themselves. Just because, because it's based in our nature,
not the specific event.
I would even make it smaller than that. I would say people are people.
So w you know, they're going to be selfish and all the qualities of people.
So any situation you put it in, put that in, you should say, well,
let's look at cause and effect. If I put that person where the free money is,
you know, I should expect money to be taken, but not because history repeats.
It's just a simple cause and effect.
So if it doesn't repeat itself,
what would you say to all the history majors right now that are listening to
this? Well, what would be the point of being a historian? If not,
to have some sort of roadmap for the future, right?
Well, indeed the history is what a preventive from repeating, in some sense,
because you'd know what didn't work.
So you might see history repeat when it works. So if something worked before,
you might see somebody try to try it again.
But even you take anything like North Korea, right?
What was the main thing people said when president Trump got elected was well
talking to North, Korea will never work, blah, blah, blah. And maybe it won't,
but he got it further than anybody else. He got it into a personal level.
It wasn't anything like history.
So no matter how many times history had repeated,
you introduced this whole new variable of president Trump and then history
doesn't count anymore.
Can you make it that concept that people who said one thing two years ago say
the complete opposite. And I, I don't mean, um,
that they've flipped all their beliefs, but that it's always a team thing.
You know, it's like if, if Obama had talked to, uh,
gone to North Korea and talked to Kim Jong and they, you know,
a certain set of people, the Republicans in this case would have been like,
he's crazy. We can't talk to these people. Trump does it. We can't do it.
You can flip that the other way. I mean, that, th that,
I guess that goes to what you're saying about the team thing.
But do you think people realize the sort of absurdly I'm not talking about
evolving over a period of time with certain set of opinions I'm talking to that
because of the players are different, that you just completely taken opposite.
Yeah.
One of the great mysteries is you watch somebody who doesn't agree with you,
and they're doing that crazy thinking, like you mentioned,
and you watch them and you think to yourself, is that real? Do they,
do they really think that, and I spend time doing that too,
but one of the advantages I have is having studied hypnosis.
I understand people to be irrational most of the time,
and I understand them to be rationalizers and I understand confirmation bias and
cognitive dissonance.
So my take is that most of the time they actually believe what they're saying.
And because they can't see it, you know,
they're the ones who were blinded to it.
So it looks like it makes sense to them.
Do you think there's some reason,
like an obvious sort of psychological reason that people who seem most obsessed
by politics on a day-to-day basis, and I'm not talking about like,
sort of the broad theme stuff, but as you said before,
you you're really sort of uninterested in politics,
but the people that are obsessed with, you know, the nitty-gritty, excuse me,
the nitty gritty, what happened today? What happened tomorrow kind of,
or what's happening tomorrow?
There's a reason that they're so miserable because it's, it's sort of like,
it's like an untenable system that they're playing with all the time.
You know, people are different. So it's probably all different reasons.
I do a for entertainment and I think other people are drawn in from the fight.
You know, they, they like the fight. So what's my fight today. Ooh,
there's a new headline. Let me get into that fight. There's definitely a,
I don't know,
dopamine or serotonin in the hip that people would get just from making a good
point. It's like, ah,
got that guy said something bad about this celebrity got him
something. I think that this was a real thing.
Right? Like involving weapons, they would be much more reserved.
What do you think?
Yeah, exactly.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.